en un movimiento burocrático pero
simbólico el gobierno de joe biden
reabrió una línea de contacto directo
con washington para los palestinos la
antigua unidad de asuntos palestinos que
bajo la administración de donald trump
quedó en la órbita de la embajada
estadounidense ahora se llama oficina de
asuntos palestinos de eeuu un cuerpo que
se mantiene bajo el auspicio de la
embajada pero que reportará al
departamento de estado en los temas
sustanciales la oficina a seguir al
mando de george roll como en los últimos
años y busca abrir canales separados de
información sobre temas israelíes y
palestinos la decisión sin embargo no
cumple con el pedido de la autoridad
palestina que reclama la reapertura del
consulado en jerusalén durante años soy
casi una embajada de facto para los
palestinos esta dependencia fue cerrada
en 2018 cuando trump decidió mover la
embajada estadounidense de tel aviv a
jerusalén aunque el secretario de
estado- anthony blinken prometió su
reactivación esto podría resentir las
relaciones de eeuu con israel y desde el
gobierno de nafta ni benet han advertido
que no hay lugar para otra misión
estadounidense en jerusalén para algunos
analistas este es un primer paso en la
posible concreción de esa reapertura y
un guiño de la administración baiden
antes de una potencial visita del
presidente estadounidense israel y
cisjordania ocupada en julio próximo